what do you make of the recent uaps I
think is the new term Eric you need to
get
up with the times here they're not UFOs
anymore that's the old I wasn't even in
this game when it was UFOs okay okay so
what do you make of the recent UAP
stories and attention and response and
subsequent response
um
I'd like to ask you first
so I had a look at the uh first
whistleblower from about two months ago
quite closely with Andy Stumpf who used
to have pretty high level security
clearance and he explained to me about
how unimpressive that particular type of
security clearance is how very common
which one this is David yes David
[Music]
no not not David fravor no no David
fravor was the Tic Tac correct this is
uh Dave garoosh yes okay
um very common level of security
clearance uh that using that as some
sort of uh oh this is a legitimate
credential it doesn't really wash too
much that it was
second or it was third hand information
mostly secondhand information kind of I
heard from a person who saw or who heard
right
um it just seemed to me to be
rather on the face of it
unimpressive that release I see
what did you think
well like I've been telling everybody
um these are highly conserved stories
this is
not the only person I've heard this
story from I've heard this from multiple
people they're they're various versions
of
this Secret World which play out as
Space Opera
you know that then mj12 became the real
government that only even the president
could couldn't understand you know it's
like okay
so
that's the weird part about it until you
start realizing how sober many of the
people are who believe this and who
claim to have had Direct contact with it
and then you don't know what to do
I mean in other words
whatever this is
there is a thing
it's not necessarily Little Green Men it
could be for example that they mock up a
floating spaceship in a hangar and then
they uh
drag people past it and say whatever you
do do not look to to your left or right
or you'll be shot and then of course
people look and then like mission
accomplished now people will say oh my
God you have no idea what we the U.S has
incredible technology
and then maybe the idea is you've got to
cover story maybe you've got the your
adversary investing in things that don't
make any sense I don't know
but there's not nothing here this is not
about mylar balloons and seagulls
anymore
I'm trying to come up with a word for it
but it's like a
it's like recursive false Flags yeah in
a way where the goal is not to give or
hide truth the goal to fire hose with
information so much that the truth can
no longer be discerned it's a haystack
of
to make sure that any needle is very
difficult to find
it is yes haystacking right
yeah okay so they Haystack the crap out
of this thing I have no question that
there was something that was used to
develop U.S aircraft like the B2 bomber
and the SR-71 blackberg so if you see
something crazy in the sky better that
you think it's a UFO from outer space
than some Advanced thing from Lockheed I
have no question that we use this to
deal with things like the Chinese
balloon shoot down where we shot down
several things in a week and we couldn't
recover debris from any of them I mean
come on guys
um
you know maybe the idea is that this is
a a head fake to our adversaries to
develop the wrong things and to use
their treasure on things that won't work
maybe there's a secret program uh where
some of this stuff is actually real and
true and we're not allowed to know it
because it would be too mind-blowing
maybe there's a cult
inside of our government that has
replaced angels
with saucer-shaped aircraft
um
whatever this thing is
it's being used for many different
purposes there's something here
we just don't know what it's you know
this is the problem the princess can't
feel a p because that would be
impossible the princess feels a
disturbance
you can't say what the disturbance is
maybe it's a golf ball maybe it's a
cantaloupe maybe it's a banana
but whatever it is there's something
wrong with the mattress
yeah it seems to me this fire hosing the
goal of uncertainty hmm right
how do things muddle out who wins in a
muddle is a great question we're not
taught to ask sorry to jump in on it
yeah
always look for who is trying to muddle
to win
like very often you're in a
dispute with entrenched status quo and
somebody will say well I guess we'll
have to agree to disagree on this one
like oh well who wins if we agree to
this oh it's you
you're right
this is like an old principle of mine
which is that you can always tell who's
Guilty by who first declares a time of
healing
why why is that a razor to use oh
because if you do something wrong and
the public is clamoring for for your
blood you say there's been too much uh
blame and finger-pointing on all sides
at me
it's I I think what we need is to come
together and declare a time of healing
for me right
so I believe that in general whoever
declares a time of healing is suspect
number one
that's a very nice uh razor to use
I wonder about this
oh how would you say
epidemic of uncertainty
brilliant
speaking my language
and I wonder
how first off how is an individual you
are
supposed to put up any kind of effective
defense
to just take some sovereignty being you
know an agentic individual right
and secondly I wonder what the end goal
is I I understand why uncertainty would
be useful for manipulation because if
people can't discern truth from untruth
it can be easy to poke them and prod
them and and Float them in particular
directions
but it also seems like no kind of also
useless as well that
some people
um non-insignificant large cohort of
people will just reject it entirely
which actually they're doing which
actually makes it more chaotic and more
unruly so it makes me think well maybe
if this is the case if the fire hosing
is happening right it's epidemic of
uncertainty
maybe the outcomes were predicted but
haven't manifest in the way that was
intended
maybe there's more of a rebellious
streak say more about that I'm not
trying to understand that if people who
if you make the public very uncertain
about most things by overloading them
with information or by even the it
doesn't even need to be coordination it
could be a byproduct of having
24 7 access to the entire world's
population through Twitter and Instagram
stories and blah blah blah right there
is so much I can no longer discern even
due to a multiplicity of opinions that's
not coordinated to be a multiplicity
that go in opposite directions
if it was coordinated the outcomes that
are occurring at the moment a lot of the
time don't seem to be happening with
people just oh roll over tell me exactly
what to do there is a massive
non-insignificant cohort of people that
say I'm checking out and I now no longer
trust anybody at all and that doesn't
say anything yes and that doesn't seem
to be if the goal was ease of control
that doesn't seem to be effective for
the person that wanted that or the group
that wanted that to be the outcome
first of all
I'm really glad to get a question about
this as a sea change which is that
our lives have become wall-to-wall
uncertainty we can't discern if the
Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor today
we would spend 10 years discussing
whether it was a false flag whether it
was actually the Japanese whether there
was any attack whether it was a Sound
Stage whether it was a psyop whether it
was a you know
right now
the main institutions of our society
have abdicated
their role
for public spirited adjudication
of what is true based on expertise
and so what you're seeing is people
coming to hate experts and coming to
hate institutions because they're
realizing that these institutions lie to
them at a level that they've never
considered unless they were Alex Jones
fans to begin with
and so you're what you're having is
you're having a large number of people
waking up to the idea that
yeah there really are
organizations and working groups that
determine what you hear from a
multiplicity of venues it's the same
message relentlessly do you think people
are overly pattern matching that now say
more boy what you mean the the same
conspiracy where there isn't because the
lack of faith in institutions same
person is saying that they see a
conspiracy and they see no conspiracy
they have part of their head that
remembers that conspiracy theorists are
crazy people and they've got part of
their brain that remembers the normies
who don't believe in conspiracies are
crazy people and they can't integrate
those things
right they cannot figure out how are
these things being coordinated am I a
crazy person for seeing these patterns
am I a crazy person for ignoring them
for when they're when they're Unearthed
um
what you're seeing is a complete
destruction of Bedrock reality that if
you weren't actually physically there
how do we know that these people
actually met in a warehouse is this
really a table or is it just you know
CGI was it green and we could
superimpose wood onto it nobody knows
what's true
and
you know if you if you ask me well Eric
how are you dealing with this I would
say I'm failing
I'm just flat out failing
as are all of you I'm just more honest
about it some of you have an idea that
you've got one lens
which is fix the money fix the world
Bitcoin that's the answer yeah Bitcoin
rock on but
no that's not the answer or somebody
else says you know
I really think that we just need to be
open and tolerant and realize it's a big
world and we just have to give people
their due
well that doesn't work either you can't
just let
everything run Riot or we have to go
back to our institutions with these
people at the helm are you kidding we
have to abandon our institution wait
what are you saying we're going to
abandon our institutions
all right do you know what that looks
like
nobody has an answer in other Muse this
episode is brought to you by Shopify
Shopify is the e-commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide whether you're a garage
entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify is the
only tool you need to start run and grow
your business without any expertise
Shopify puts you in control of every
sales channel so whether you're selling
satin sheets from shopify's in-person
POS or offering organic olive oil on
shopify's e-commerce platform they have
got everything covered for you Shopify
Powers 10 of all e-commerce across the
United States massive Brands like
gymshark still use Shopify that's how
powerful it is so if you want to start
selling something anything online
Shopify is where to start you can begin
a one dollar per month trial period
right now by going to the link in the
show notes below or heading to
shopify.com
modernwisdom that's shopify.com modern
wisdom to take your business to the next
level well today thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Eric then press here for the full length
three hour episode
go on
press it